So guys I saw a pretty cool idea floating around the internet.
And that was to take plastic bottles and cut them out and use them [for] spoons bowls and funnels.
Which is a really cool idea except the spoons that I saw being made looked very very weak.
So I thought today we would try the idea, see what modifications we can make,
and share those ideas with you.
Now, I don't usually drink soda, but when I do I drink root beer.
But it's not really going to matter which bottle you use as long as it's got these little knobby things on the end
You can see there are five little knobby crowns on the bottom
and the coke bottle and the standard Soda bottle are a little bit different,
but that's not going to make much of a difference by the time we're done with it.
Now, there are a couple of different ways that you could approach this
if you want to make a spoon you're gonna have to use the
Entire length of the bottle including one of these knobby things and I'll show you how to do that in a second
But instead let's start off with something simple. Let's start off by making a bowl now check this out
If you look really closely near the bottom here you [can] actually see there's already a line drawn for you
So if you take something like a knife or a pair of scissors and just cut along that line
It instantly transformed your soda bottle into a nice Makeshift Bowl
Let's move on to making the spoons next
These little nubs at the bottom of the soda bottle are gonna make the actual spoon,
the rest of its going to form the handle.
And this is how it's going to work. This is a spoon
I made it from a previous bottle and I'm just using it as a guide here
So it all starts by sketching out a spoon pattern on the bottle you
Don't want to go all the way to the bottom you want to cut about halfway up
and
Just make it look as close to a spoon shape as you can and then go ahead and cut it out with a pair of
scissors
when you've got all of your spoons drawn go ahead and cut the top of the bottle off and you can reuse this as a
Funnel so it's not actually garbage it can be useful you can use this for filling your car up with gasoline
Transferring water back into a tank. It's even got a screw on and screw off
Lid so if you need to you can hold material in here until you need to let it out
Now that we've got the top cut off we can very easily access our stencil lines here
So let's go ahead and cut them out one by one
We ended up with five different spoons that look pretty cool
There's still a little bit rough so you might just want [to] go around and clean up the edges one more time
with a pair of scissors, and they will get you by it a pinch however there is a problem with them now these spoons
Do look pretty cool and it's a great idea however
They're extremely flimsy you guys you can't pick anything up with this spoon you put in your cereal
And it's just going to flop over and you can't pick anything up, but there is a simple little trick
You can do to actually make it quite versatile and quite functional
put your finger right into the center [of] the handle and press upward and tell the two sides touch and
continue creasing it all the way down to the spoon part what's going to happen is this will add a lot of rigidity and a
Lot of strength now. I around at this end of my handle as well, just for decoration
I think it looks cool and ends up looking rather decorative just by making that very simple fold right down the middle
It's added quite a bit of tensile strength you can see if I hold it now. It doesn't move anywhere, so considering
This is just a little plastic spoon hacked out of a bottle
[I] think it's going to do the job quite well
So just [like] that
We've turned a couple of soda bottles into a really cool Little Bowl and five
Makeshift spoons that look really awesome, and actually work, really
Well as well now you could use these for cereal you can use them for oatmeal
You could use them for pretty much anything even mashed potatoes
They're very robust very durable and the cool thing is they don't cost anything
There are actually a ton of uses for plastic bottles. I've seen a lot of ideas floating out there
this is the one that I wanted to try another one that I thought was cool is just taking your water bottle cutting out a
Few sections and folding the top over the bottom and just like that you have yourself a little makeshift camp mug.
So we got our bowls our spoons and our mugs
What else do you need. So thanks so much for joining me for this experiment guys?
I've enjoyed hanging out with you, and I'll be looking for you the next video. Talk to you then
That might be the thumbnail right there that looks wicked awesome